sumo wrestlers embody the ideal Japanese
male powerful discipline fierce the
highest ranked wrestlers or grand
champions are called Yokozuna and are
like gods the wrestlers sleep eat and
train together today
I assure you stable will begin a series
of intensive practices but first the
ring must be purified in a ceremony
dating back over a thousand years
branches chase away evil spirits salt
purifies the ring and sake brings good
luck
with the gods appeased practice can
begin the rules are simple yeah touch
the ground with anything but your feet
or get pushed out of the ring and you
lose
the average match lasts less than 10
seconds nearly anything goes but
wrestlers can't pull hair hit with a
fist or choke their opponent only the
highest ranked wrestlers are permitted
to wear white the rest in black fight
for rank the physician even understand
so the item additional crews look who's
about to go to lesson one
different techniques are used to toughen
wrestlers spirits after beating an
opponent in practice its traditional to
drag the loser around by his hair until
he collapses in exhaustion
malicious or they don't want a story
Keaney Oh
Shindo my character key visual media
modern Yogananda see
well in yawns - monolith dividend on
something supernal tomorrow apples no
parole chicken animated a man
eating is an important part of training
the goal is to become not just big but
also strong tramadol okie over not a
beauty is gonna keep on shopping online
school oh nice a little exciting in
order to build a solid sumo body a
wrestler eats about 10,000 calories a
day more than three times that of the
average male the sumo specialty is a
thick stew called chanko nabe it's full
of chicken fish beef everything you need
to bulk up and drinking lots of beer
also helps
but the final secret to building a sumo
body is what you do after you eat every
day
the huge lunch is followed by a lengthy
net to make sure the weight stays on